foreign
school that Newton told us that weight
is proportional to Mass
I think everybody remembers that
Einstein told us that energy is related
to Mass
unfortunately these are the these guys
explained where the masses come from in
the first place
and that's where our friend Peter Hicks
comes in and there's his formula written
on the Blackboard behind him
and uh I actually have his formula
permission on my t-shirt here I hope you
can read it
by not expecting you necessarily to
understand it at least there you are
his theory could be written down in a
formula on a t-shirt
now it's a key aspect of his theory that
there should be an additional particle
beyond the ones that we've had on the
previous slide and that's what we call
the Higgs boson so
I just want briefly to try to explain
how his theory works not in any
mathematical technical detail but just
to give you some idea of what the idea
is so you should imagine that the space
is filled with some sort of Universal
Medium
much like Siberia in the middle of
winter where there's a thick layer of
snow everywhere now what happens when
you try to cross that snow field
well if you're lucky
you've got skis you will skim across the
top of the snow
you go very fast and that's like a
particle without mass that does not
interact with the Higgs field that fills
the universe
an example of such a particle without
mass is the particle of light what we
call the photon okay so no Mass
no interaction with Mr Higgs you
traveled at the speed of light
but maybe you have snowshoes
in that case you would sink into the
Higgs snow field
you interact with Mr Higgs
you go slower than the skier and that's
like a particle with mass like the
electron that always travels at less
than the speed of light
and then of course a few really unlucky
you might be stuck in Siberia with only
your boots in that case you're going to
sink very deeply into the snow you're
going to go very slowly like a particle
with big Mass
okay so that's the basic idea a
universal Higgs medium and the strength
of your interaction with that Medium
tells you how much your particles weigh
of course the next question is
what is that snow actually made of and
of course we know what regular snow is
made noise made of snowflakes
and according to Mr higgs's Theory the
fundamental constituent of that
Universal field is the particle that we
call the Higgs boson that's the analog
of the snowflake
so this was the theory that Peter Higgs
proposed in 1964
and I personally got interested in 1975
and I tried
with my two colleagues to think about
what a Higgs boson might look like in
experiments
another time all these ideas were
regarded as being very speculative
and at the end of our paper you know we
were a little bit cautious
we say we don't want to encourage big
experimental searches for the Higgs
boson
fortunately Our advice was not taken
and
something like 30 years later
Large Hadron Collider the LHC came into
operation at Sun designed precisely to
look for the Higgs boson and to answer
some of gogas other questions
so here's
the tunnel of the Large Hadron Collider
it's about
100 meters Underground
the circumference of the tunnel is 27
kilometers
and billions of particles go around and
they make maybe billions of collisions
every second
and with those collisions we hope to
recreate what happened in each of Dark
Matter maybe where the matter in
Universe came from and other godang
questions
so it's one thing to bang protons
together then you have to look what
comes out to actually need very big
complicated detectors and these are
pictures of the detectors uh during the
time of their installation
and you can see how big they are if you
look at the upper right hand picture you
will see a person not a Lego person a
real full-size person
so these detectors were put together by
scientists from around the world
literally thousands of them from dozens
of countries so the discovery of the
Higgs boson that I mentioned in the
moment was made at CERN
but not by silent was made by these
thousands of physicists
just a little comment it
in order to enable all these physicists
to work together and share their data
Tim berners-lee whom you see here
invented the World Wide Web at CERN a
little over 30 years ago
I don't think he or anybody else
may be understood the revolution that it
would make in our world in our way of
life throughout the world
and I think that we all owe a very big
debt of gratitude today
to Tim berners-lee for inventing the
World Wide Web
where would we be without it
in the time of covid we rely on the
world wide web for communications like
this video conference
we rely on it for Commerce for ordering
our groceries online
and for entertainment
Netflix Spotify Instagram
etc etc
so
son through 10 bernersley through the
World Wide Web I think
plays a big role in our everyday life
let's get back
to beat pigs
and 2012 when his particle the Higgs
boson was discovered so this created a
lot of excitement in the particle
physics community
which I characterize as mast hicksteria
so what was this triggered by
well it was triggered by two of the big
LHC experiments Atlas and CMS
discovering events collisions which have
the characteristics expected for the
exposure and here's one example from the
atlas experiment
so this is a computer image of the
detector
you see
yellow lines those are charged particles
you see blobs where neutral particles
came out without leaving tracks
and you see four straight red lines
those correspond
two four particles that might have come
from the decay of a Higgs boson
this is another example observed by the
CMS experiment
again you see this curved orange charged
particle tracks
and you see two straight red lines
corresponding to lots of energy being
deposited by a pair of neutral particles
probably photons the particles of light
and that was something that we had
calculated back in 1975 with my
colleagues
so I'm listening CMS announced that they
had seen these interesting events that
they discovered a new particle
and particle physicists got very happy
so here you see the scene in the sun
notorium uh everybody is therefore
and this is a picture that I
particularly like because on the right
you see Peter Hicks and in the middle
you see a colleague of his photo Anglia
who posed a theory centipede Diggs
and although they proposed their Theory
48 years before the discovery of the
exposure
they had never met this is the instant
when they met
and uh it's no secret that Peter Higgs
had tears in his eyes and this particle
was finally discovered
so anyway that's one reason why I like
this picture the other reason
is because uh yeah circled in red
you see Fabio de janotti who one of the
physicists to announce the discovery
that day and is now search direct to the
general so uh
we at least at CERN we don't have any
glass ceiling
so Discovery exposed form was a big deal
without it there would be no atoms
because electrons would fly with the
nuclei at the speed of light
to be no heavy nuclear
weak interactions responsible
radioactivity would not be weak Not only
would we glow in the dark life would be
impossible everything would be
Radioactive
so Discovery as he Exposed on was a big
deal a lot to Peter Hicks
so what else are we looking for now
so
to just give you a flavor of this
I want to uh borrow
from James Bond
with one or two small modifications
also paraphrasing the title of the movie
instead of the world is not enough I say
that the standard model of particles is
not enough
why to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas